Baby girl, I won't mind if you play tennis badly.
I won't mind if you choose to never pick up a racquet.
But I beg you, in this game of life, please keep playing no matter what.
Just like it taught me, sports will teach you to be strong.
You'll discover the power and grace of your body.
You'll learn to move and you'll learn the way to move others.
Sports will teach you the strength of your allies.
Whether your bond is by blood or by ball,...
...whether she shares the color of your skin or the color of your jersey,...
...you'll find your sisters in sweat.
Sometimes you'll score goals, sometimes you won't.
But the goals you set, you'll reach together.
You'll find the courage to stand tall, work harder,...
...and speak louder on whatever playing field you choose in life.
So, keep playing, my girl.
Keep playing.